non-minimalists
i want to go back to amy's question
though real quick because like
how do you recommend i teach my
eight-year-old daughter about quality
versus quantity regarding gifts
and i think that the trap that i've
fallen into
is exactly what she says how do i teach
my child
you don't need to teach your child
anything regarding quality versus
quantity
that truth if she's open
and paying attention if you don't
if you don't try to change her even
though
right now you know her preference sounds
like it's it's quantity
if you don't try to change her and she's
open
she'll probably discover that at some
point
like oh i don't need all these things i
i just want the one good thing or maybe
she won't
and that's okay like there's no this way
is right and this way is
wrong and i think especially with our
kids the more we bring in that
moralizing
the harder it is for them to figure out
who they actually are
and to feel confident in them as per as
people and again i'm saying all this
because i'm
so bad at it right and i'm i mean i'm
learning
a little bit by bit like how to
not be the the teacher
the quote-unquote parent who instills
the right
values you know and um
yeah the implicit message in amy's
question is
how do i teach her the good instead of
the bad
how do i convince her that this is good
and this is bad yeah
right and anytime we convince someone
even if it's our own child we try to
convince them
of something it places us on a pedestal
i love what you said there back she said
you don't need to teach your child
anything that will sound crazy to some
parents who are watching this or
listening to this right
and we just spent a ton of time on this
maximum episode we're an hour and a half
in at this point of this maximal episode
and we talked about how persuasion
is not consent trying to persuade your
kid to do something and ryan a moment
ago talked about boundaries setting up
boundaries for
your child well there's only one reason
we have to set up boundaries for our
children
it's because we've placed them into a
society that will damage them
yeah and so some boundaries if you are
living in society
are necessary ella you can't play in the
in the street because a car will hit you
and it will kill you now
the hanza that we were talking about a
moment ago there's no street for their
kids to play in
there there's no parenting going on with
real humans
the hadza because there is not in a
society around them to inflict pain
and misery onto them no but there are
boundaries still
right they teach their kids about lions
yeah yeah elephants
yeah yeah right um the things that will
harm them right right so there are
boundaries
yes but yeah the the teaching
um especially with
respect to like i at least my view of it
right now is like
is this is good and this is bad right
like you can teach them how to
shoot a bow and arrow or whatever you
can teach them how to go hunting for
deer
yeah you can teach them anything
mechanical right right there are things
you can teach your children and it's not
right or wrong
yeah but um i think what you're just i'm
sorry i don't have to but i think what
you're trying to say is is that
you don't need to convince your child of
anything yeah
because that's what i think that's the
context of what teach is here yes
there are mechanical teachings that you
need to teach kid how to read and write
right
i mean even that like kids will learn if
they're around people that know how to
read and write
that read and write on a regular basis
kids will learn how to read and write
without having to be taught and i'm i'm
literally experiencing this
intensely right now with ella because
she has been slow
to learn in air quotes how to read she
has not
um been receptive
to the teaching that she's received on
reading
and instead of
like i think what we think is oh if we i
just teach her this way this way this
way
then she'll get it at some point no
she'll get it when she's
not feeling pressured and stressed and
anxious about it when when you're not
forcing it upon her when you're not
and she's started to you know actually
feel
bad right about herself because she's
having
she's being told indirectly
that she's not good enough because she
she hasn't learned this thing
and i think that's i know that's not
what amy's doing with with
teaching her daughter about quality over
quantity but in a way
when when we do this sort of stuff we're
saying your preference for
quantity is bad
and kids internalize some kids obviously
more than others but like
they they'll internalize that and and
see it as like
you think i'm bad or you think part of
me is bad
right so yeah we'll get back to that
i'll just repeat this because we might
make this a quickie for youtube here but
i think that we mistake
quality as good quantity
as bad but as we said a moment ago if
you go to a beach with three grains of
sand you're going to ask for more
quantity
so it's always going to be situational
it's going to be personal as well
and if your child does prefer quantity
with respect to something over
quality we don't need to moralize that
and say well that's actually wrong
here's the better way to do it yes for
me and for
bex and for ryan i know that we tend to
prefer
quality over quantity in many areas like
i would rather have
four ounces of delicious coffee yeah
then
24 ounces of mediocre gas station coffee
right right and yet for someone else
they might say well i really want the
quantity here
and who am i to convince you otherwise
right did you enjoy this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast
and youtube channel one hundred percent
advertisement free